لقد ذهبنا إلى عدد من البلدات هنا في
محافظة إدلب في سوريا وشاهدنا
العشرات من المباني التي سويت بالأرض بسبب الزلزال،
وقابلنا اليوم
العديد من الأشخاص الذين يحفرون
الأنقاض بأيديهم العارية
باستخدام أدوات الحفر المؤقتة
الأدوات بكل ما يمكنهم العثور عليه حقًا لمحاولة
تحديد مكان أحبائهم،
الناس هنا ليس لديهم الكثير، وأغلبهم
يعتمدون على منظمة International
Eight وهؤلاء هم الأشخاص الذين
نزحوا من منازلهم عدة مرات
بالفعل على مدار أكثر من عقد من الزمان الماضي
بسبب هذا الصراع في سوريا،
وصلت مساعدات قليلة جدًا حتى الآن إلى هذا
الجزء من البلاد،
وينتظر الناس بشدة
المجتمع الدولي الذي يقولون إنه
يتذكر سوريا والسوريين الذين تحدثنا إليهم
اليوم مع امرأة واحدة في رسالتها إلى
المجتمع الدولي، هل كانت هي؟
تريد شيئًا واحدًا فقط،
فهي تريد خيمة، وهي مجرد خيمة
جومانا كراتشي، مقاطعة سي إن إن المهملة في سوريا